qui a déjà repris un ou une ex après
s'être retrouvé sa terre à la vérité a
repris quoi une exilée y ce quatuor près
qu'une ex aurait déjà pris avec ma
première absolument comment j'allais 1
absolument absolument c'est ça ouais
donc juste d'autres aventures ça s'est
arrêté
et puis on s'est retrouvé à mal sa place
ou pas le dire bah sinon nouvelle bien
tassés comme tu dis son prénom commons
appelé je n'en ai beau moi la première
lettre famille si ces [ __ ] eyrolles
[Rires]
c'est carole vous ai jamais repris à
l'exo ont valu dix mille fois mais bon
il ya dix mille fois attend déjà avec
qui on est une histoire mais en général
il faut jamais leur faire parce qu'en
les raisons pour lesquelles on s'est
quittés reviennent en trois secondes
d'almere faire ça ouais ouais c'est le
conseil que je donne et vous vous êtes
déjà au prétexte qu'ils étaient encore
vivants
[Rires]
moi j'ai essayé quatre fois et j'ai mis
tout mon coeur aucune n'a voulu à quoi
c'est fini c'est fini
remy finit mal mais quand on se
débarrasse du typhus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la coop en cas d'arrivée au but alors il
ya une meuf qui est derrière comme ça
éclate l'onu rendent eric idle plus les
quatre hommes et cinq ans elle applaudit
on dirait qu'elle est aux césar elle est
comme ça avec autant de oui et donc
ouais mais y en a eu que j'ai tout fait
j'ai escaladé le balcon j'ai campé une
semaine sur le palier ah ouais j'ai un
livre est là et qu'elle sortait les
poubelles je remontais avec derrière
elle et tout ça ben si bas depuis lé
pari qu'elle serait plus jamais vous
voulez on est resté en bons termes
c'est vrai et vous ben moi une seule
fois et je crois qu'on est ressorti
ensemble à peu près douze à quinze fois
bah c'est mon ex vous connaissez bah oui
laquelle ben mon ex car les dernières
quatre ensemble mais c'est vraiment
poitiers avant sur mettait parfois on
s'en moque ou trois jours ça s'arrête ça
on se met ensemble trois jours il ya
trois jours sa partie est resté deux
mois ou sur qui tu es mais à chaque fois
il y avait comme quelque chose qui nous
est montée et on pouvait payer à chaque
fois ils avaient convoyé à l'autre tu
vas bien et puis ça repartait comme un
cas comme on remet un peu indécent break
mal éteinte selon le faire-part fait ça
toi je crois que ça intéresse vachement
ses biens et ou kaki et vous vous aviez
après qu'alex jamais assez que quand
c'est fini c'est plié ebp avec déclics
mexique bat calmez-vous quand même